[Musique]
monsieur le président du sénat cher
gérard monsieur le président du parti
populaire européen cher joseph monsieur
le président des républicains cher
laurent monsieur le président des
centristes fier et monsieur le président
du groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée nationale cher christian
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat chea bruno madame
la secrétaire général cheikh a ni madame
la députée chère brigitte 1
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
et les élus
cher françois xavier cher comme il à mes
chers amis
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue à tous en ile de france
avant toute chose je voudrais que nous
puissions tous collectivement nous unir
à l'hommage national qui a été rendu
hier à cédric de pierrepont et alain
berton cello nos deux commandos de
marine qui ont mené jusqu'au bout du
sacrifice leur engagement pour la france
et je voudrais que nous associons à cet
hommage la mémoire de tous nos
militaires tombés en opération loin de
leurs foyers pour défendre les valeurs
qui nous sont chères
je vous demande s'il vous plaît de vous
lever pour une minute de silence
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
alors mes chers amis ce soir ici porte
maillot
notre rendez vous c'est d'abord le
rendez vous de l'amitié et je voudrais
vous raconter une histoire il y a un peu
plus de trois ans lors d'une campagne
régionale au couteau notre adversaire
politique claude bartolone qui était à
l'époque le président de l'assemblée
nationale
n'avait pas hésité avec un parfait
cynisme à franchir toutes les lignes
rouges de la morale politique en
m'accusant de vouloir défendre les
intérêts de la race blanche
quelques semaines seulement après la
tragédie du bataclan qui avait endeuillé
tout le pays
il a voulu racialisée la campagne
régionale en espérant coalisés contre
nous et la gauche et la banlieue
à ce moment là un jeune philosophe élus
de versailles qui n'appartenait encore à
aucun parti politique a pris sa plume
pour dénoncer ce qu'il fallait bien
appeler par son nom
un racisme à l'envers l'attak de claude
bartolone et l otan plus irresponsable
quel attiser les haines au lieu
d'apaiser une société française qui
était encore sous le choc des attentats
alors ce philosophe qui est venu avec
beaucoup de panache nous soutenir
vous l'avez reconnu vous l'avez compris
c'est et toi françois xavier
[Applaudissements]
en 2015 suite est là et aujourd'hui
c'est à mon tour d'être là à tes côtés
dans cette campagne qui rassemble des
personnes qui me sont proches à la fois
par l'histoire et les combats politiques
partagées je pense à arnaud danjean
spécialistes reconnus et respectés au
parlement européen sur les questions de
défense
mais je pense aussi au trio de l'étape
d'abord agnès evren ma vice présidente à
la culture qui défend en ile-de-france
une stratégie ambitieuse d'accès à la
culture pour tous
la culture qu'elle sera placé au coeur
de l'identité européenne
tu as également dans ton équipe frédéric
péchenard mon vice président à la
sécurité
là aussi nul doute qu'il sera apporté
son immense expertise à la sécurité
notre continent qui est aujourd'hui
tellement fragilisé par les menaces et
enfin il y à geoffroy didier mon
vice-président logement avec lequel je
mène une lutte acharnée contre les
quartiers ghettos ce qui enferme leurs
habitants dans une spirale mêlant
délinquance communautarisme et
radicalisation nous voulons les détruire
et les reconstruire
nous mobilisons les faux socios européen
pour cela alors oui notre rendez vous de
ce soir c'est celui de l'amitié
mais je crois que c'est aussi le
rendez-vous de la fidélité fidélité à
une famille politique les républicains
qu emmanuel macron à l'essai pour
moribonde en juin 2010 est englouti
croyait-il par la vague en marche
et bien si nous sommes si nombreux ici
ce soir porte maillot
c'est pour le dire haut et fort
la droite n'est pas morte non le centre
n'est pas mort nos valeurs ne sont pas
mortes fait du bruit
je crois au contraire que jamais nos
solutions n'ont été aussi nécessaire à
la france
pourquoi eh bien d'abord parce que la
france est en overdose fiscale mais les
baisses d'impôts financé à crédit et les
chèques sans provision à trois semaines
des élections
ce n'est qu'un miroir aux alouettes et
je le dis il n'y aura pas de baisse
d'impôts durable sans baisse des
dépenses baisse des dépenses publiques
alors évidemment pour ça il faut du
courage et c'est ça peut-être qu'ils
manquent au gouvernement
mais la france est aussi en crise
d'autorité nous ne pouvons plus de voir
semaine après semaine les émeutiers
saccagé et pillé les centres villes il
ne sent plus depuis longtemps des gilet
jaune
ce sont des cagoules noires qui veulent
déstabiliser nos institutions
alors quand est-ce que le gouvernement
va prendre enfin les sanctions
dissuasives exécuté sans délai cher
frédéric pour ramener l'ordre dans notre
pays la france est enfin en crise de
cohésion quand nos territoires ruraux
abandonné s'appauvrissent quand nos
banlieues abandonnées se communautariser
se radicalise la république recule et ce
sera à nous de lui redonner son nom
égalité fraternité laïcité
aujourd'hui j'en ai la conviction la
france a besoin de nos idées de notre
courage et de nos convictions parce que
nous nous sommes ceux qui choisissons et
qui choisiront toujours la liberté
contre l'égalitarisme la responsabilité
contre la culture de l'excusé l'esprit
d'entreprise contre la bureaucratie et
la solidarité contre l'assistanat
nous choisirons aussi l'amour de la
nation et l'envi d'europe car nous
sommes fidèles à l'ambition du général
de gaulle le général de gaulle il voyait
la france grande dans une europe
indépendante des autres puissances et et
face aux volontés hégémoniques des états
unis de donald trump de la russie de
vladimir poutine gh de la chine de chic
shipping à la menace terroriste
islamiste déséquilibre migratoires plus
que jamais nous devons peser influencé
changer une europe trop bureaucratique
est trop faible
c'est pourquoi nous devons plaidé
aujourd'hui pour une france plus forte
dans une europe plus politique et plus
puissante
une europe qui soit protectrice et
conquérante à la fois
notre rendez vous ce soir c'est donc
aussi celui de la nécessité la nécessité
d' incarner une autre voire une
alternative à la fois emmanuel macron et
à marine le pen
oui il faut incarner une troisième voie
nous ne sommes ni marine le pen qui
prétend défendre la france en
affaiblissant l'europe ni emmanuel
macron qui prétend défendre l'europe en
affaiblissant la france
nous nous sommes à la fois patriote et
européen
regardez madame le pen qui s'allie avec
le conseiller de monsieur trump qui
s'allie avec vladimir poutine dont le
seul objectif commun c'est de casser
l'europe que dit steve banane l'homme
qui a fait donald trump
il dit je le cite je vais planter un
pieu dans le coeur de l'europe
je vais planter un pieu dans le coeur de
l'europe
peut-on être plus clair alors ce n'est
pas la france que marine le pen défend
c'est la fin d'une europe puissance qui
nous protège qui nous projette et qui
nous renforcent dans le monde
le front national prétend défendre la
france
mais c'est en réalité aujourd'hui le
parti de l'étranger
les nationalistes en europe sont des
impasses des impasses pour leur peuple
et il faut regarder en face leur premier
dégât l'italie l'italie est en panne et
affiche une croissance zéro que monsieur
salvini se révèle incapable de ranimer
la grande bretagne
quant à elle sombre dans le chaos
politique
le break site est une telle impasse que
les britanniques n'arrive pas à lâcher
prise et à sortir de l'europe alors même
que les relocalisations d'entreprises se
multiplient alors disons le haut
populistes de tous poils
quand on dit au peuple ce qu'ils ont
envie d'entendre le de leur dire la
vérité quand on multiplie les boucs
émissaires plus tôt pour se défausser de
ses responsabilités ça n'a jamais fait
ça ne fera jamais un cap une direction
une ambition pour une grande nation où
on le populisme c'est non alors
regardons ensuite monsieur macron
hélas hélas on ne peut quand même
qu'être frappé choqué du décalage entre
les paroles et les actes
le président est un fervent adepte du
double langage et les français en font
les frais concrètement dans notre région
double langage quand emmanuel macron
prétend qu'il veut renvoyer les migrants
clandestins dans leur pays alors qu'en
même temps il m'oblige à rétablir 50% de
réduction dans les transports pour les
clandestins que j'avais supprimé
et il s'étonne ensuite devoir se
concentrer sur paris les doubles in et
les doubles ine ce sont ces migrants
clandestins sont arrivés dans un autre
pays d'europe
pourquoi vient-il en ile de france ils
viennent bénéficier de la prime à
l'illégalité macron
double langage quand emmanuel macron dit
vouloir lutter contre les travailleurs
détachés et qu'il critique
en même temps la clause molière que j'ai
instauré alors c'est quoi cette clause
molière mais c'est une clause qui impose
un traducteur
lorsque les ouvriers la chantier ne
parle pas le français pour leur sécurité
alors ça renchérit bien sur le coup des
travailleurs détachés et ça limite le
dumping social européen est bien le
gouvernement est contre heureusement
nous avons eu juridiquement gain de
cause
et aujourd'hui je vous le dis la clause
molière elle est appliquée dans tous les
marchés passés en ile-de-france double
langage enfin quand emmanuel macron
prétend défendre le principe de
subsidiarité house a vu le principe de
subsidiarité c'est de dire on laisse aux
états ce qu'ils font mieux et on donne à
l'europe que le minimum ce qu'elle doit
faire
donc il prétend défendre le principe de
subsidiarité prétend lutter contre la
bureaucratie européenne
et pourtant nous apprenons que nos
trains de banlieue 9 tellement
nécessaires dans la région nos trains de
banlieue neuf risque de ne pas pouvoir
circuler parce que la règle européenne a
changé et que désormais c'est bruxelles
qui fixe l'espacement des fauteuils à
l'intérieur des trains
même ceux qui ne roulerons jamais en
dehors de nos frontières et
le gouvernement auquel j'ai fait appel
refusent de nous donner une dérogation
pour deux centimètres des espaces entre
les fauteuils
elle est où la subsidiarité combien ça
va coûter combien de retard vont prendre
les trains alors immigration
travailleurs détachés normes absurde
champions industriels européens qu'on
n'arrive pas à la sphère politique
agricole commune qu'on n'arrive pas à
défendre autant de signes de
l'impuissance française en europe
autant de sujets sur lesquels nous
n'avons pas su imposer nos points de vue
et en votant république en marche
qui peut croire que ça va changer
personne alors oui la droite et le
centre rassemblés ont une troisième voie
incarner celle d'une france forte qui
assume le retour à l'ordre les réformes
courageuses l'esprit d'entreprise est
une vraie ambition sociale et qui veut
une autre europe maîtresses ses
frontières fière de ses valeurs prête au
rapport de force avec les autres empires
qui construit des champions européens
qui impose une vraie réciprocité
commerciale avec des barrières sociales
et environnementales
voilà ce que nous voulons incarner voilà
la nécessité pour nous les républicains
et les centristes
mes chers amis nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans la dernière ligne droite
il nous reste dix jours pour convaincre
10 jours pour réussir le défi de
l'élargissement de la droite dix jours
pour faire revenir à nous les électeurs
qui nous ont quittés pour soutenir
emmanuel macron oui enfin il faut les
faire revenir alors on va d'abord leur
part les uns on va les convaincre
[Applaudissements]
j'entends seriné une petite musique
le seul argument du gouvernement
emmanuel macron serai là pour faire
barrage à marine le pen il faudrait soit
disant voter utile et donc voter pour
eux mais le président de la république
se trompe et il vous trompent parce que
le barrage à marine le pen il se fait
pas en france il se fait au parlement
européen et au parlement européen
emmanuel macron et singulièrement isoler
ces élus ni de droite ni de gauche vont
être décent partie fixe du parlement
européen
ils pèseront peut et leurs voix ne
porteras port alors que nos élus
républicains et centristes siègeront eux
au parti populaire européen le premier
parti d'europe aux côtés notamment de la
puissante cd ou allemandes le parti
populaire européen que nous présidons
aujourd'hui grâce à toi cher joseph
c'est lui le vrai rempart contre les
dérives nationalistes que le pen ou de
salvini
il est donc indispensable que la france
qu'ils soient fortement représentée pour
ne pas aussi laisser le leadership de
l'europe à nous allier
d'europe de l'est ou d'europe du nord en
bref il faut un ppe fort face aux
extrêmes et au sein du ppe il faut un
couple franco-allemand équilibrée et
c'est pour ça je vous le dis le vote qui
fait barrage au front national c'est
nous le vote qui renforce la place de la
france au parlement européen c'est nous
le vote qui pèsent en europe c'est
encore nous
alors mes chers amis il est temps que la
france s'inspire à nouveau l'europe et
il est temps que l'europe inspire à
nouveau le monde nous devons renouer
avec l'époque pas si lointaine où
nicolas sarkozy alors président de la
république
au sortir de la présidence française de
l'union européenne en 2009 imposait son
leadership en europe et nous fixait
comme cap je le cite
c'était notre slogan 2009 quand l'europe
veut elle peut
alors oui soyons fidèles à ce message
je vous demande de vous mobiliser
il reste dix jours françois xavier toute
son équipe compte sur vous
mobilisez-vous en avant pour l'europe et
pour la france
[Applaudissements]